[Music]
how do i prepare myself adequately to
have uncomfortable conversations with
people
you touched on it earlier josh about
being kind
about being self-aware
uh
i i mentioned being compassionate
like these are the ways that you have um
meaningful conversations with people now
you can do your part
that doesn't mean they're going to do
their part their part and that's okay
but how do you prepare for it you
prepare for it in that way how can i
come at this compassionately how
how can i uh come at this and show the
other person they understand where
they're coming from
because that's really what we want we
want to be loved we want to be
understood
um which you know we could argue why we
why those are you know common ones
but
that's that's how difficult
conversations happen you show people
that like hey i love you and i
understand you
um and if you take that approach
it's still a difficult conversation
they're called difficult conversations
for a reason
but um i know in my experience they go
uh you know as smooth as they can go
they don't go perfect but it's a lot
better than if i come at someone being
accusatory
right and i think that's what makes the
conversation even more uncomfortable at
times so i would just step back and say
what makes your com your conversations
uncomfortable
what makes the conversation
uncomfortable quite often it's the need
to be loved
as opposed to showing up and just being
loving
because you can show them be loving
regardless of whether or not you need
their love you need their validation you
need their
veneration you need their approval
if you show up and you're loving if
you're compassionate you're
understanding what makes the
conversation uncomfortable
needing a particular outcome it could be
validation it could be i need to
convince them of something else as soon
as you need to convince someone of
something you are unloving them and so
that's not showing up in a loving way so
what is making your conversation
uncomfortable it's almost always because
it's tethered to an outcome either you
need something from them
or you need them to change yeah in
either way if you can let go of the need
it's no longer an uncomfortable
conversation for you yeah yeah man
that's i love that like letting go of
the outcome
and just focus on having that
conversation yeah without an outcome in
mind because yeah because that's what
starts
that's what at least with me it makes me
start to um
yeah try and convince try and pivot and
then often that leads into blaming and
here's where i'm unhappy you know and
it's okay to be unhappy but um but yeah
if you let go of the outcome then you
can just have an honest conversation and
if you approach it as an exploration
together
rather than here's where we need to go
because here's where we need to go it
means there's a destination and i need
to drag you along even if you don't want
to go there
in order for me to be fulfilled i need
to make you unhappy i need to make you
uncomfortable i need to make both of us
uncomfortable in order to get where we
need to go
if you don't need to go anywhere then
you can explore together maybe you'll
end up where you wanted to go in the
first place or maybe you'll end up
somewhere else that is considerably
better than the original destination you
planned or maybe you'll both go in
different directions because that's the
best thing for you yeah did you enjoy
this video if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free